can you envision Michelle Trachtenberg
starring in Twilight she in fact very
nearly landed a role in the popular
vampire franchise though It ultimately
didn't pan out as she revealed to US
Weekly in 2011 there was definitely
interest here and there because there's
only so few pale girls in Hollywood but
as it turned out Trachtenberg had
already signed on to other projects that
conflicted with Twilight so she couldn't
commit as she bemoaned I guess schedules
never worked out being a part of
Twilight would have undoubtedly lifted
trachtenberg's career to new heights and
maybe if she backed out of another
project she could have made it happen
regardless she tries not to spend too
much time looking back and wondering how
things might have been different as she
put it hypothetical answers mean you're
not living in the moment and you're
looking negatively at what you're doing
now